Also willkommen bei Philip Cast eine neue Folge
mit ja wer geht es dir eigentlich gut
Richard Holton Ich bin ein Philosoph aus
Cambridge mm-hmm also du bist ein Professor
in Cambridge ich bin und gestern hattest du
einen Vortrag in einem Moralpsychologie-Workshop hier
in München was  Was ist Ihr
Forschungsgebiet, das Sie auf diesem Gebiet haben? Ja,
in diesem Bereich haben Sie einige Bits
geforscht, also habe ich
in den letzten 10 Jahren oder so viel mit Psychologen über Sucht gearbeitet,
insbesondere mit
Kent Barrett in Michigan, und er hat es getan  Eine
Sichtweise der Sucht, die
eher vom Wollen als vom Mögen getrieben wird. Daher
interessiere ich mich unter anderem für
die moralischen Konsequenzen einer
Denkweise über Sucht, die
meiner Meinung nach insbesondere zeigt, dass bestimmte
Theorien darüber das Richtige sind  Was
die Vorlieben der Leute betrifft, ist es sehr
schwer aufrechtzuerhalten, ja, weil man merkt,
wie die Vorlieben durch sehr
einfache mechanische Geräte verschoben werden können. mm-hmm, das ist
eine Sache, die mich interessiert, die mich auch
interessiert  Sie interessieren sich für Themen rund um
Selbsttäuschung, an denen ich
in letzter Zeit gearbeitet habe, und im moralischen Bereich
interessieren sie sich besonders dafür, wie
Menschen teilweise moralisch
motiviert sind durch so etwas wie
Selbstsignalisierung, das heißt, dass Sie sich das zeigen
wollen  Sie sind ein moralischer Agent
und diese Leute haben gedacht, dass dies
bestimmte Phänomene erklären könnte, wie zum
Beispiel die Art und Weise, wie sich Menschen, wenn
Sie eine moralische Frage neu formulieren,
manchmal sehr unterschiedlich verhalten, ja,
und das scheint seltsam, wenn Menschen
wirklich hinter der moralischen Wahrheit her sind, wissen Sie
Sie sind wirklich darauf aus, das Richtige zu
tun, warum mit einer umgangssprachlichen Umrahmung, aber
sie würden es nicht tun. Ja, ich bin
eine Antwort, auf die einige Leute
angedeutet haben, dass sie sich unter diesen
Umständen nicht mehr
als Schauspieler betrachten können
Nun, selbst wenn sie das Schlechte tun, weil sie umgestalten
können, können sie das, was sie tun,
auf eine andere Weise darstellen,
aufgrund des Suchtteils. Haben Sie das
gehört?  Meine Forscher fanden heraus, dass es
nur der Kontext sein könnte, in dem Sie
leben, der Sie süchtig nach
etwas macht, so dass etwas mit
Ratten getestet wurde und es Ratten in einer
wirklich traurigen Umgebung gab, und
einige in einem Rattenpark, was Spaß machte  und
dann wurden sie nicht süchtig, obwohl
sie die Droge haben könnten, ja, also
gibt es viel mehr Forschung darüber, jetzt
, ich meine, es scheint klar, dass das
eine gewisse Wirkung hat, und sicherlich denken die meisten
Ansichten, dass kontextbezogene Hinweise
wichtig sind  Es gibt zwei Probleme in
diesem Zusammenhang, nämlich die Art und Weise, wie
kontextbezogene Hinweise wichtig sind. Wenn Sie
also in einer bestimmten Umgebung süchtig sind
und woanders hingehen, werden
die Hinweise manchmal entfernt und
Sie kehren dann genau in diese Umgebung zurück
und werden gerettet  Ein anderer hat
mit dieser Frage zu tun, ob es bei
den Experimenten im Rattenpark
so aussieht, als ob die Ratten
etwas Interessanteres zu tun hätten
, anstatt es zu tun  Er nimmt jetzt Drogen, es hat
sich herausgestellt, dass es eine Grenze dafür gibt, und deshalb werden
sie sie wissen, dass
sie unter bestimmten
Umständen weiterhin Drogen nehmen werden, aber es ist sicher, dass
es da ein Problem gibt, richtig, ich meine,
es gibt ein Problem, wie viel sie
tatsächlich mögen  it mm-hmm
du hast gestern hier in einzigartig auch einen Vortrag gehalten
nein ich habe nicht auf deinen Aufenthalt gegeben
okay ich gebe eine Art in der Woche
okay du wirst eine geben kannst du uns
die Take-Home-Message davon sagen okay so  Ich
möchte, dass du auch gibst, also ist einer um
eine Zeitung herum und einer ist ein Stiel, also ist
einer mit dem Suchtzeug beschäftigt, über das wir
gerade gesprochen haben, ja, und
insbesondere mit der Frage, ob
es einen Weg gibt, die Idee zu retten, die das
bevorzugt  Befriedigung von Vorlieben
ist das, was wir
angesichts dieser Erkenntnisse aus der Sucht tun sollten, okay, also
schaue ich mir dort zum Beispiel
Präferenzmodelle höherer Ordnung an, damit Sie
wissen, ob Sie eine Vorliebe für eine
Vorliebe haben, die den Unterschied ausmacht,
oder  ist t  Hier eine Möglichkeit, die Präferenzen zu waschen,
sodass nur bestimmte
zählen. Ich meine, meine Botschaft zum Mitnehmen, es
gibt keine, ich glaube nicht, dass es eine gibt, und ich denke,
wir müssen uns wirklich von einer
präferenzbasierten Theorie des Guten und entfernen
hin zu etwas, das kognitiver
ist, das mehr mit unseren Überzeugungen darüber zu tun hat,
was ihnen gut tut, als nur,
was wir uns wünschen. Okay, also das ist ein Papier,
das andere Papiere über Selbsttäuschung, also kommt es
teilweise aus diesen Themen heraus, in denen
Menschen versuchen, sich selbst eine Geschichte zu erzählen
und ich interessiere mich dort besonders für
die empirische Literatur,
ob Selbsttäuschung eine Art
aktiver Prozess ist, bei dem Sie bis zu einem gewissen Grad wirklich dabei sind
oder verstehen, was Sie
tun, und sich dann gezielt manipulieren,
damit Sie das sind  Wissen Sie, das ist
die altmodische Ansicht und gegen ihre
verschiedenen Leute, die auf eine deflationärere Ansicht drängen,
die besagt, dass Nein nicht
der Weg ist, dies aktiv zu tun, haben wir
nur bestimmte eigennützige Vorurteile, ja a  Und
mein Verdacht ist, dass die empirische
Literatur tatsächlich nicht zeigt, dass
sie nur zeigt, dass es mehr als
eigennützige Vorurteile sind, aber Sie brauchen
dort viel philosophische Arbeit, um zu sehen, was
die entscheidenden Probleme nicht sind, also bin ich teilweise daran
interessiert
Was ich daran mag, dass
Sie in dieser Forschung den Fokus darauf legen
, dieses empirische Verhalten zu finden, und bei
vielen Menschen verhalten sie sich tatsächlich
so, und das ist etwas,
das interessant ist, weil meine nächste
Frage lautete  wird sein, was ist
Ihr Ziel der Forschung, warum machen Sie
es, in welche Richtung gehen Sie
, ja, ich glaube, Sie
wissen, dass Ethik historisch immer eine
Art Zusammenarbeit war, oft innerhalb
derselben Person von Menschen, die über
empirische Verhaltensfragen und Denken nachdachten
über die normativen Fragen rund um das
, also wissen Sie, wenn Sie Aristoteles lesen,
wenn Sie die Ethik lesen, verstehen Sie sehr gut,
dass er eine Theorie darüber gibt, wie Menschen
arbeiten und so  Es ist in eine Theorie
darüber eingebunden, was sie tun sollten,
drückt es nicht ganz so aus, aber wenn
Sie wissen, wie ein gutes Leben
für einen moralischen Agenten wäre, und ebenso wissen Sie
, wenn Sie sich Hume ansehen, wenn Sie sich
viele ansehen  die britischen Sentimentalisten, wenn
Sie sich Nietzsche ansehen, das sind alles
Philosophen, die sehr an
diesem Wechselspiel zwischen normativen
Fragen und deskriptiven
Fragen zur Moralpsychologie interessiert sind, also
denke ich, ich denke, wir
setzen diese Tradition sehr fort, okay, ich meine
einige  Philosophen gehen sehr, sehr a priori vor
und denken, dass wir nichts davon
lernen können, wie Menschen sind,
hmm, das uns hilft, darüber nachzudenken, wie wir sein
sollten, und ich denke, das ist, ich denke, jede
Theorie darüber, was wir tun sollten,
muss auf der Theorie von basieren  was wir mögen,
und ich sehe diesen Punkt, es ist wirklich so, als
ob Sie sich aus
dieser Situation herausgeholt haben, als ob Sie nicht sagen würden, dass
ich diese Forschung mache und ich hineingehe, als würden
Sie sich selbst als
einen sehen  irgendwie eine kleine Rolle in dieser ganzen
Philosophiegeschichte, aber so
etwas schätze ich, denn
wenn du dich manchmal fragst, was machst du
eigentlich, was ist dein Ziel, dann so, als würde ich das
tun, bis du es getan hast, und du hast
dich einfach erledigt, also ja, ich  meine, und ich
denke, besonders wenn Sie anfangen zu
denken, dass die empirischen Fragen
hier wichtig sind, weil es keine
Fragen sind, die Philosophen, selbst eine Gruppe
von Verlusten, die für sich allein arbeiten,
richtig konsultieren können, und Sie müssen
mit Psychologen und mit ihnen arbeiten
Neurowissenschaftler, ich bin mit Evolutionstheoretikern zusammen
, und wie auch immer, der
gestrige Workshop war interdisziplinär, er ist
interdisziplinär und er ist
auf eine sehr tiefe Weise kooperativ, richtig, ich
meine, dass die II denken, dass die
Fragen, die die Leute stellen,
eigentlich komplementäre Fragen sind, und das
sind sie nicht  werden beantwortet Ich
glaube nicht, dass die psychologischen Fragen
beantwortet werden können, ohne dass eine Menge Arbeit
klar wird, was wir tun  Es
gibt also eine Sache, die die Philosophen
tun können, aber ich glaube nicht, dass die meisten
Philosophen an expliziteren
normativen Dingen interessiert sind, ja, und viele
Psychologen interessieren sich dafür, dass
Psychologen denken, dass es ihre Aufgabe ist, nur zu
beschreiben, was Menschen tun, und
sie sind dort, wo sie aufhören  Schlimmer noch, uns
interessiert auch,
wie das damit zusammenhängt, was die Leute
am Ende des Videos tun sollten.
Könnten Sie uns sagen, welche normativen Gäste
oder Meinungen Sie mögen würden, was
wir, was wir tun sollten, was Politiker
tun sollten?  Diese Frage oder was anderen
Kollegen gefallen sollte, ja, was ist Ihr
Ansatz zur Ungeheuerlichkeit?
Wir arbeiten weiter an einer andauernden
Übung, um herauszufinden, was die
wichtigen Fragen sind und was die
wichtigen Denkweisen sind, also ist es
nicht so, dass wir o denken sollten  f Philosophie
als eine Art Arbeit, indem man mit einem
bereits bestehenden Satz von Fragen beginnt, also haben alle meine
Kollegen
gestern genau das gesagt, wir haben auch
einen Satz von Fragen und wir
versuchen einfach, die Antworten zu erarbeiten  Für sie
passiert mit moralischem Denken, dass
Sie erkennen, dass Sie sich darüber klar werden,
was die Fragen sind. Sie sehen, dass es in der
Wissenschaft richtig ist, dass es nicht so ist, als ob
Sie wüssten, dass die alte Wissenschaft die
gleichen Fragen hatte und nur andere Fragen hatte
Antworten darauf auf die
zeitgenössische Wissenschaft Die Wissenschaft schreitet voran,
indem sie den konzeptionellen Rahmen verfeinert,
in dem sie arbeitet, und das
Gleiche gilt für die Ethik. Ich denke, Sie wissen also, dass
viele meiner Studenten sich Sorgen
um Fragen der Sexualmoral und der
sexuellen Fluidität machen, die Sie wissen, dass wir es nicht sind  war vor
zwanzig Jahren ein Anliegen von jedem,
also ist das allgemeine Thema rund um
Transsexualität und Geschlechtergrenzen und was auch immer das eine
neue Sache ist, und wir müssen anfangen,
mehr darüber nachzudenken  Wenn Sie Fragen zum
Klimawandel und zur Klimaverantwortung kennen
, stehen wir wirklich erst am
Anfang. Ich denke daran, einen moralischen
Rahmen zu schaffen, der uns hilft, darüber nachzudenken,
und es gibt ein Problem oder das, was Sie
sagen, für das einige Leute versuchen, alte
Fragen zu verwenden  Die neuen Fragen Ich denke,
ich denke,
ja, ich meine, ich denke, Sie müssen
denken, dass sich das Framework tatsächlich
entwickelt. Die Art und Weise, wie Sie darüber denken,
entwickelt sich, also denke ich, dass Sie wissen,
dass wir nicht in der Position sind, in der wir sind  kann
denken, wir haben eine übergreifende Theorie, Sie
wissen schon, Utilitarismus oder Kantsche Sichtweise oder
so, und sie wird einfach alles beantworten,
was wir nicht
tun, so dass wir es irgendwie von unten nach oben
machen müssen  kleine, detaillierte
Dinge, und wenn wir uns diese kleinen,
detaillierten Dinge ansehen, erhalten wir Konzepte,
die teils normativ und teils
beschreibend sind, und dickflüssige ethische Konzepte,
wie die Leute darüber denken, und das sind
Dinge, an denen wir arbeiten, und es ist, wie Sie
wissen, es ist es  schwer zu tun, dass es
harte Arbeit ist, sich nicht nur
mit den moralischen Fragen zu beschäftigen, nicht nur
mit den empirischen Fragen, man muss
sich gleichzeitig mit diesen beiden beschäftigen
, das ist wirklich, ich muss zugeben, wirklich
interessant, mit Ihnen zu sprechen, denke ich  Die
Videokuration ist am Ende in Ordnung, also
sollten wir gut anfangen. Vielen Dank, wie die
Leute
Kontext des Moralpsychologie-Workshops ist
der Link in der Beschreibung und ja,
bis zum nächsten Mal